welcome to this deep dive instagram
business growth strategy training i'm
fired up because in this video you're
gonna be learning the five huge
instagram trends and really mistakes
that people are making in 2022 and how
to fix them and our guest trainer today
chalene johnson is going to be teaching
on the biggest mistakes that you're
probably making how to fix them the
latest changes on instagram and there's
a lot so buckle your seat belt
tips for boosting your reach and the
best practices for winning on instagram
but probably most importantly is
actually how to monetize your social
media in a 2022
world how do you actually build a real
business you're going to want to buckle
your seatbelt for this entire training
and if you're watching the replay take
advantage of chapters and time codes
specifically on youtube but all of that
and more is coming up today
on the grow with video live show
[Music]
welcome back to the grow with video live
show i am so fired up to have one of my
friends personal business mentors social
media mentors and one of our speakers
this year at grow with video live
chalene johnson on the show in the house
chalene how's it going what's up
great i mean that intro wow i feel like
i'm on like a live tv show this is high
high tech high production value man
we're high tech out here and uh smash
like if you're just joining us now
listen i want chalene to get into the
training immediately but if you haven't
heard yet she is actually doing
four free trainings it's called
business growth week and you can hear
more about it or register at
thinkbusinessweek.com we'll tell you a
little bit more about that later but uh
chalene is literally all week long it
starts a little later this week giving
you a ton of free training on social
media tactics on social media monetizing
your social media building your online
business sales it's going to be
incredible and so check out links around
the post or specifically in the youtube
description um but chalene i'm excited
for your training today so we can just
crack right into it yeah and i think we
need to because we have a lot to cover
there's so much that's changed on
instagram and and there's a lot of good
news and there's a lot of opportunities
that didn't exist before so i think we
should jump right into it all right well
i'm gonna fire it up and uh i'll be
joining you throughout the training
today here we go okay
so uh do i need to share my screen or
are
full screen and all right
being shared and then just go full
screen on your slides and we're ready to
rock all right let's go
okay are you seeing my screen my uh
slides oh you are okay but not not in
play mode yet we got you how about that
beautiful here we are all right so five
biggest mistakes in social media that
people really need to avoid in 2022
i'm assuming that most people here
watching are using social media because
uh you're trying to monetize it you'd
like to make if not a side hustle a
full-time living from social media
that's my instagram handle it's at
chalene johnson but i always preface
that by saying um
some of what i'm going to teach you
you won't see me putting into practice
because i have
almost 800 000 followers and the rules
are different depending on how sizable
your following is so how well known you
are so i'm assuming what i'm teaching
today is applicable to you if you have
under 200 000 followers
and for some of you even if you have
more than 200 000 followers um which by
the way congratulations
this stuff still applies
uh so first i want to just quickly blow
through some of the things that are low
growth trends
meaning
these things aren't working as well
there's always going to be exceptions to
the rule there's going to be someone who
you're going to be like wait a second i
know someone who's doing that and
they're killing it i would just say look
at their insights because you could be
wrong you might assume someone's killing
it because they're doing these things
but if you looked at their insights they
might not be
growing one of the first things that's
just going away thank god is the overly
branded or overly themed grids you know
where like everything was kind of pretty
and matching and follow the sequence
single photo post
low growth
long content
meaning longer videos
and long captions now don't let that
discourage you to my youtube friends um
there's so many ways for you to
repurpose your longer content and this
is actually a good thing long captions
they're on the way out it doesn't
surprise anyone i don't think is our
our attention span is like nothing right
so there's always going to be exceptions
but for most of us you can keep shorter
captions um overly personal feed content
that's something that really worked well
in 2018 today we ain't got time we've
got time to follow people who are
showing us a little bit of everything
on their feed we're not going to follow
you i want to see that in your stories
but on your feed post we want very
specific valuable content
posting product or personal promotion
that's a lot of peas
to your feed that ain't working try it
and you'll see
and then too much variety
you know like showing us too much of
what's going on and too much behind the
scenes and and and too much of like what
your life is all about on your feed so
we're really talking about these low
growth trends this really relates to
what's happening in the feed post here
are some things that are trending upward
share worthy content the kind of content
that people are like this is so good i
got to send this to like my group text
or i got to send this to my friends or i
need to share this to my stories because
it says something about me
original audio reels
thank god because i don't know about
y'all but like i'm
kind of sick of um the lip sync reels
now no offense some of them are great
and some people do a really great job of
it but the dancing and and lip syncing
other people's content it's it's
that trend
is um slowing down an original audio on
both tik tok and
instagram is blowing up and by the way
everything that i'm sharing with you
applies to
really youtube shorts it applies to
instagram and it applies to uh tiktok
and and frankly for that matter youtube
what i'm going to share with you
single subject accounts by single
subject i mean like things are accounts
that are super niched that's blowing up
doing multiple posts per day i know
that's kind of a bummer for some people
they're like what i can barely keep up
with one post today well multiple posts
per day you're going to understand in
this training how to do that quicker
and stories that really maintain
engagement as opposed to being like a
monologue
and then curiosity those these are the
things that are trending upwards so if
you're trying to see growth
if you want to see growth on any of your
social these are the things that are
really making a difference and it's
really important that you think about
this because there's so many more people
now on social like i see here's so many
people saying
i think i'm shadow band because
my engagement's gone down i used to get
so many more likes like two years ago
yeah but our attention span has been
splintered
because twice as many people now are on
all the social media platforms number
one number two is most of us are
following way too many people
so that means we're very particular
about whose content we are looking at
and not regularly looking at other
people's content
you stop
the algorithm stops showing it to people
so people haven't engaged left
shared your content
if they like you and maybe they would
like your content they're not seeing it
what we have to do is get the attention
of the less than you know 20 accounts
that we look at on a regular basis so
most of you i'd love to see in the chat
let me know
how many people you currently follow
on uh instagram
sean do you know how many people you
follow
uh too many i feel like uh right and and
i follow 3059
looking at yeah
and um i just was debating that recently
like what am i even doing here and a lot
of times like i'll follow a lot of our
students and i'll follow different
people and i follow people from the past
what i was thinking about was cleaning
out you know how many people i follow
and how bad about it i'm definitely not
seeing all those posts
it's absolutely not and and you know
there's content that we might want to
see might actually be valuable for us
but the bottom line is this this is just
this is how we're behaving now in social
we aren't looking at even
10 of the people that we're following so
the question really becomes how do i how
do i
become one of those accounts where
people are actually oh i got to see i
need to go check so-and-so's account how
do we do that and and the way to do that
is by making certain that you are so
valuable people are like i gotta go see
it not like i like this person and i
want to see what they're up to we just
don't have time so the way that you
stand out is well the number one mistake
people are making is that they're
creating
content that's just confusing
i'm not sure why i'm looking at your
content
you know it's
and it kind of boils down to what we
used to do where it's like well you want
to show people who you are you want to
be authentic you want to show them a
little slice of life and let people know
who you are which is true in stories but
on our feed posts it's just confusing if
i follow you because you are um
an an expert at nfts and i
when i go and look at your content that
day it's a picture of like you and your
family on a vacation you're like what is
this and then you have to go back and
look at the person's account and if you
go back to their account and there's
like some nft stuff some family stuff
also they're running a marathon and
preparing for that and we're seeing how
they're eating i'm just confused and i'm
gonna on if i don't unfollow i'm
probably gonna mute it and if i don't
mute it i'm just not going to engage
with it and the first time you don't
engage with a post that you've looked at
it drops lower in the algorithm and
eventually not too long after that
instagram just won't even show your
content to that person anymore so what's
the fix
the fix is a difficult pill to swallow
but you've got to niche down none of us
want to do that everybody i know because
you're multi talented you've got
multiple interests there's more
dimensions to you there's other things
that you could be promoting but if we
don't niche down no one's ever gonna see
our content in our feed post you're
gonna hear me keep saying that in our
feed posts there's a place for us to see
all the parts of you but it's not in our
feed posts our feed posts need to be
down and i think the word niche scares
people so think of it this way just pick
a topic
pick a singular focus pick a pick one
subject and stick to it
like more than 80 of your posts should
be that one niche that one subject that
one focus and this is hard for people to
do and i'm wondering let me know in the
chat if you are like
i can just post about
one topic i can do that
or if this is a struggle so either type
i can do that or this is a struggle
and you know you're honest to admit that
it's a struggle but that's the fix so i
want to share with you some case studies
these are all accounts that
myself and i really should say my team
helped me to manage and grow
these are all
what we would call niched accounts
themed accounts feature accounts
whatever term you want to call it but
generally speaking these are accounts
where we're only posting one type of
content
for one type of very targeted avatar
so you know you can see how
home workouts that's all that we post is
very specific workouts for women who are
it's very specific working out at home
have minimal equipment and they are
intermediate to advanced fitness gals
women ages uh 25 to 35 it's very
specific
instaclubhub
that account has grown very very fast
the only thing we post there is things
related to growing your instagram
uh push me daily is adhd content
and um brock's account which is growing
at a rate of about
1500 new followers per day um and that
started happening he was like at 80 000
followers last year and he started
growing this fast once he like didn't
before he was talking about all social
media things which isn't niched enough
that's like that's a topic but it's not
niched enough but once he started saying
okay all i'm going to do is specifically
post about instagram growth with reels
like that is so specific and it just
blows up
so here's another case study this is one
of our students um uh charisse had 724
followers when she started with us
and did not
did not want to
pigeonhole herself she felt like you
know by people that some people really
like this content some people really
like that content we said all right
do a little test let's just see what
happens if you can
really niche down to one specific type
of content i want to share this with you
i was shocked it worked my falling shot
through the roof in less than 30 days i
grew by over 10 000. her following shot
through the roof she grew by over 10
000. we can't hear the audio super loud
but she was shocked by the results that
we're observing on screen right now
yeah less than 30 days
uh she went from
under a thousand followers to 11k
followers um
but she really like for she did not want
to do this she forced herself
to really niche down and thought that
she was going to lose a lot of momentum
this is what happened
after she continued to do that now she's
at over 40 000 followers and and so this
does work for just about anybody this is
another one of our students you know
they were killing it they were doing
snowboard injury prevention right um
which seems pretty niched but then they
niche it down even further and started
doing snowboarding this
sean i swear we had this conversation
when we were snowboarding in park city
you were asking me about what yoga
moves you could do or like you know yoga
for snowboarders straight up and that's
all the posts now and look what their um
following went from
5000 to 42 000.
and they were so afraid to do that
they're like oh that is like you know
isn't snowboarding niched enough
like snowboarding injury prevention
we're like well not really yes it's
niched but what just what would happen
if you niched down
way further
and that's how you stand out it's just
how you it's i know it's scary but it is
the way to grow really really fast you
know here's brock's story again he was
teaching
um
social media in general and just by like
going straight up how to grow with reels
it's insane his growth is insane i'm
sure it's higher than for
now because it's been a couple days
since i made that slide but the good
news is and i hope you find this
reassuring is that your stories can
still be about everything and anything
but they still have to be very
interesting and valuable and they have
to engage people
number two biggest mistake that people
are making is weak bios
like you're
so let's talk about this and sean you
can take me down for just a second
when you
the last time you looked at a great
piece of content right and you're like
oh this is good
and you're thinking yourself i would
like more of this
what's your behavior you go and you look
at the person's account
and the first thing you do is you you
quickly look at the bio
and that has to pass the test if that
doesn't pass the sniff test that tells
you i'm gonna get more of what i just
saw
then you're out but that's step one is
like the the bio has to say to the
person who just looked at that piece of
content they're like this is good i
would like more of it if they look at
your bio and it's like
oh i have no idea what they what they
post about
then you're probably not going to get
that following and the way to fix this
is pretty easy you got to optimize your
bio and this is a really important thing
for everyone to do it's not the easiest
to do so i want to take you through an
actual case study um this is someone who
is in network marketing and like most
people she's got things in her bio that
are cute
um maybe they say something about her
personality but i don't care
i want to know what's in it for me right
so she says i am currently unable to
quit as i am currently too legit okay i
get it she's an emcee hammer fan
we have that in common but that
i don't need to know that
underneath that she says i teach five
minute makeup tips now that's that if
i've just seen one of her makeup tip
videos that should have been at the very
top because most of us don't even have
time to read two sentences we're gonna
read one sentence so the very first
sentence of your bio better make me go
like oh i'm gonna get more of what i
just saw
okay
also you see underneath where it says
sient top leader and then underneath it
um it says entrepreneur well cn top
leader that is the space where you are
putting your name on instagram but your
account handle in most cases is already
your name so you you want to use that
space wisely that's the only area in
your bio that is search engine not
optimized so
and this is what our content looked at
like before okay so i've let's just
assume let's just pretend let's just
pretend that i just saw a great
five-minute makeup tutorial from her
first of all her picture doesn't say she
does makeup look it does to me it's like
is she at the gym with a mask on i don't
get it you know what i mean so that
already is detracting from her message
um but once i see five minute makeup
tutorials i'm gonna look i'm gonna give
her like ten more seconds of my time and
i'm gonna glance at her most recent
posts and i'm gonna go
dude there's i don't see any makeup
tutorials i'm out i'm already out i'm
out maybe there are some that she posted
a week ago but they're not showing up in
these first you know 9 10 15 posts that
i can see so i'm out i'm done so here's
what we did for a makeover
first change a photo zoom in on your
face
ideally i would like her background to
be lighter so that it's not so dark but
you need to look right here
i don't care how cute you look that day
and your body looks great and your kids
are with you ain't nobody can tell
because your phone i've got the mini
mini mini phone i got i bought the
little teeny tiny new iphone br everyone
teases me because it's so little but
like literally
the screens are so small you can't even
if it needs to be your face okay now
look what we did to her content we
changed her bio to read listen to this
first of all
put her title to be something that
people are going to search for so to
take advantage of the search engine
optimization we changed it to quick
makeup tips that shows up underneath her
photo underneath that it says five
minute all natural makeup tutorials for
moms over 40 very specific niche
i help women who want to look like they
have it all together in five minutes or
less it's a very specific niche now look
at the content you glance at her content
you're gonna say number one i love she's
showing other people's five-minute
makeup tutorials not just hers so i'm
not just gonna get one style i'm gonna
see myself in some of these images and i
can just glance at this and see that i'm
going to get the type of content that
she's promised me in her bio so that's
just a very quick
five minute you know bio makeover and
we've got a really strong call to action
schedule your zoom consult and and a
link tree
simple
now if i'm looking for more five minute
uh makeup tutorials i've changed my bio
but my content still looks like her old
content she's not going to get my follow
right she's got to change her content
and her bio so that's how we can um
really take advantage of first of all
the search engine optimization and the
fact that you've got about 10 seconds to
convince someone that you are worth a
follow
right so here's a breakdown of what
everything is there's her username is at
the top we've got a profile picture that
is nice and tight
um we've got her niche and what what i
it is i can expect if i follow you
because you know the biggest mistake
that most people i think make on in
their instagram bios is they turn it
into a resume where they'll say like um
i am an author a podcaster and i love
life you know it's like it's like a bot
it's that's great it's a resume it's
awesome which is what worked in 2021 but
now i don't have time i don't i don't
care what you did i just need to know
what do what do you do here on instagram
what are you doing on instagram why do i
need to follow you because i'll figure
out who you are after i look at your
stories then we've also got her niche
statement a link which is her call to
action
um the title which should be search
engine optimized and then if you want
you can put in a little credibility
there which is basically what you do
number three mistake hey sean how are we
doing any questions you want me slow
down
no i love this and one of the things
that um you uh mentioned uh that
especially kind of in think media where
we teach you know production was you
mentioned her profile picture was good
with the more close shot uh but because
she has black hair and a dark dark
background she kind of disappeared and
one of the things that i i love that you
do
and we think about the same is just
contrast so what color is your hair what
is maybe even your skin tone brock is
doing something similar especially with
that color background yeah and uh we we
recently did it i kind of tried to
figure out what's your color and we
actually have a tutorial we'll link it
up on um on omar talks about just taking
like a paper background you could tack
it up on the wall and you could either
just splash an led light on it but
getting that contrast as well as that
close-up headshot i think was a really
great point as well as of course all
your bio optimization tips and so smash
like if you've been getting value so far
we're talking about these five big
mistakes and we're going into number
three right now uh chalene so i'm fired
up not posting enough yeah just to walk
it back real quick to that profile
picture you can just take a um a selfie
right now
because it doesn't need to be high
quality take a selfie the next time you
you know whatever take a selfie on your
phone and you can use an app like canva
or an app like um
pixel cut and it'll remove your
background for you it'll give you a
bright give you lots of different
options of a round
uh you know bright background that
matches your brand or that's a contrast
to your hair color
and and it just it's you can have it
done in like less than two minutes so
canva pixel cut those are both simple
apps to do that they'll remove your
background for you just like yeah the
remove background feature is amazing in
canva i know right yeah okay well number
three mistake um and and this is one
that's hard for people because they're
like i'm so freaking busy
but i'm gonna solve it for you
um is you're just not posting enough
okay so here's the deal you want new
followers because the followers you have
right now
they're not engaging
and
they're they've already had an
opportunity to become your customers
you've got to reach new people who
specifically are served by your niche
who need the solution that you provide
that's how we monetize our social media
isn't it isn't by going viral it isn't
by attracting tons of people it's by
attracting people specifically or who
are like yes this is exactly
what i need this person can help me this
person has what can take me to the next
level create that transformation save me
time save me money they have what i need
and the only way
you ever have an opportunity to reach
new people is when you do a post
so follow me for a second
if you do
six posts a week you've got six
opportunities to attract new people
you double that and you're gonna double
your growth
because we're all following too many
people the trend is most of us are
trying to unfollow every single day
which is why if you're not posting
you're losing followers
even if you haven't posted your every
single day every hour that goes by that
you haven't posted you're losing
followers that's just part of the
attrition process but every time you
post something new
you're you're offsetting that balance
so you're going to see your growth
happen much faster and that's how you
fix it you just got to post more but
specifically post reels right now on
instagram right um
post more to tiktok post more to youtube
post more to your youtube shorts post
more to facebook but if when you're on
instagram post reels
and that content can be repurposed it
can be repurposed over to every platform
i just mentioned including i forgot to
mention pinterest all the platforms are
shifting over to giving a lot of
attention to short form content short
form videos right and so why not take
advantage of that by using the reels
function right now reels are performing
22 better than any other type of feed
post
that's that's huge
and get this shorter reels do better
so by spending even less time you've got
a 22 percent chance of
seeing more growth so what what's here
are some trends i want you to get ahead
of when it comes to reels original
content
and the way to know what's trending is
to just think about what's
bugging you like what you're like i'm so
sick of that if you're sick of it i
guarantee it's trending down
so just because you're seeing everybody
do it doesn't mean you should do it like
pay attention if you're like that i find
that so annoying
everyone else is about to find it so
annoying too
so what's really working right now is
very very short original content your
original audio because instagram is just
it's just responding to what we do and
don't like
so short original content short original
audio huge
um creative production
and creative production doesn't mean you
have to um
have a production team it doesn't mean
you have to be super creative it means
that you're thinking about
production like what grabs people's
attention
even if it's just a quick phone
transition where you know you're using
your phone it looks like there's
movement that's what i'm talking about
i'm not talking about you know using
special apps although there are some
great ones out there
but creative content is going to grab
people's attention and shorter content
is blowing up
hey can i give everybody like a really
quick um
hack right now that'll just like blow
your mind
i would really like the hack personally
i think i speak for everybody yes
okay you got to take me off screen for
just a second i'll give you this one all
right here we go so cool okay so what
works
insane right now and i this is i don't
know how long this is going to last but
it's it'll work right now
is take i want you to look at your
insights and take
either a photo or a text post you know
like when you do one of those quotes or
whatever take the one that has performed
the best for you in the last year
okay take that it's a singular photo or
post right and then i want you to take
make a screen recording of that photo
or um text post a screen recording
that's like two seconds
okay crop it so it's square now it's a
video now it's a video that is one to
two seconds
but it's already piece of content that's
proven to have performed well for your
account which means the algorithm is
already set up to respond and say people
who follow this account love this type
of content but now it's a video which
instagram loves so you're gonna post
that one to two second video
and it will blow up here's why because
people don't even especially if it's
something that's going to take more than
one second to read
so people are going to take long they're
going to watch that video probably for
five seconds which means you've got five
times the view right so people are like
wow this the average person watches this
500
of the video
so algorithm responds to that and it'll
show it to more people try it it's super
easy you already created the content
instagram loves it trust me it works all
right let's get to your number four
mistake let me just speak to that this
is why you're my personal
instagram sherpa
um and we've been applying that and you
can see this right here for example is a
video so it's a one second looping video
and it got 21
434 views because it's just you know
it's a still image and even you know
again it's the growth video live show
and we're so pumped that chalene is one
okay this is we've done the same on an
image that's an actual video but we are
doing it consistently where it's just a
looping image and we will use static
images just like that one with where you
can see chalene in the corner there
super powerful tips which by the way
before we get into uh number four and
number five if you're loving this
obviously chalene is just scratching the
surface and if you haven't heard she's
doing a whole week it's called business
growth week of free training 90 minute
trainings four of them they're all free
and if you haven't registered for that
yet it starts later this thursday i
believe think businessweek.com or check
the comments or check the description
highly recommended if this is the kind
of information you like plus you can see
obviously we're getting results by
applying everything that we learned from
chalene her team as well as i believe
brock on the team is going to be
teaching and her husband brett yeah i
can't even wait for
thinkbusinessweek.com yeah you know what
we did just to give people a little
perspective on it is everyone's at a
different level so rather than trying to
serve everyone on each
workshop i said you know there's people
who don't even know yet what to monetize
like they don't even they don't even
really have a business idea they're
creating great content they love social
but they really don't know what okay
that's a specific workshop we're gonna
do there are people who do know what
they're monetizing but they have no idea
how to make it sales happen on social
that's a specific workshop right and it
doesn't make sense for you to go to that
one if you don't know what you're going
to sell so we really did each one of
these workshops for very specific
audience
and i know we said that they're 90
minutes that's really the q a but if you
just want to get in and get out those 30
minutes look at the titles of each one
of the workshops because they're not for
everyone each one we've designed for a
very specific person so that we can
really deliver stuff that you know takes
you to the next level that last little
hack that i just gave um by the way
that will help you like it's an
important hack because
yeah it works but more so the reason why
i like it is because i don't want you to
spend
more time than you need to
on social media like we're making it too
hard
and so when we take something like that
it's like i already created this and
less you know such a small percentage of
your audience is seeing your content
every day anyways so take what you know
worked
works and produce it for them in a
different way okay the number four
mistake can i is it okay to move on sean
absolutely i was just showing uh some of
the ways you're doing it with one second
videos this one has a cool little c
caption for help which is man we're
seeing that's that's a whole so you got
the uh yeah anyways i i'm distracted
you're out here you're crushing at
chalene johnson all right back to the
deck back to usually okay so the number
four mistake is um self-focused content
um and i think most of you are probably
going to be relieved to hear this
because i don't know about you but there
are most days i wake up i'm like i don't
have anything interesting going on
my life isn't instagram worthy today i
don't know what to say about myself i
don't know what to post about myself i
don't look cute today i don't i just
don't know what to post that's what most
people struggle with and the good news
is that type of content isn't performing
as well i mean unless maybe you're a
kardashian other than that
that's not what people want to see what
people really want is content that's
oh this is so good that i want to share
it so it's share worthy content so that
usually means if okay just think about
the last thing you shared to your
stories why did you share it
you didn't share it because your friend
did an amazing job of editing themselves
they look beautiful their waist is
snatched and they're on a lovely
vacation with their gorgeous family you
don't share that content nobody shares
that because frankly no one other than
like your closest friends and your
parents really care
you know we just don't but the new
person
they want contents like okay what what i
want something that's
valuable to me
and so when we share content we're
sharing content because it's we're like
okay i'm gonna share this because it's
gonna be valuable to my followers i'm
gonna share this to my friends in my you
know group chat like i'm sure you guys
all have a group chat where you
you have to see this tech talk you have
to see this instagram reel you have to
see this youtube video still think about
what it is
that motivates you
to share content and then you want to
create more of that content and i know
that can sound
kind of
vague so i'll try to break that down a
little bit more but when you share when
someone shares a post of yours what
they're doing is saying
hey i want everyone else to see this
person it's like they're giving you
the stamp of approval to all of their
followers so not only are more people
discovering you
but the right kind of people are
discovering you because there's people
who already follow you and love your
content so the more shares you get the
more followers you are likely to get and
that happens only when we're creating
really great
um content that people find shareworthy
so my suggestion is before you make your
next post you have to ask yourself
is this valuable enough that people
would share it
because there's a lesson there's
motivation there's a tip there's a
how-to there's
anything funny
anything that like this this says
something about me it says something
about you know what i stand for that's
the kind of stuff that people share
okay the number five
mistake
this is a big one
is ignoring what works
and this means you're not looking at
your insights
and when i say
ignoring what works here's what i'm
talking about
we're so focused on likes and comments
but yet we can't understand why our
account isn't growing
so the one thing i urge you to do is
start looking at
your insights to know
what content
is actually attracting the most new
followers
because that's a heavy heavy assignment
today
most of us are not like i don't know
about you but i'm so stingy with my
follow today like i'm like
it's good but i can't follow i can't
follow one more person so if somebody
actually gets my follow
i'm like this is good i want to see it
again
it's valuable to me not it's a little
bit interesting not all this person's
attractive not all this person has a a
fascinating life we don't have time no
one cares anymore so you if you really
really want to make a difference in
social you've got to create
content that people it's so good that
people are following you because of it
so i urge you to look at your insights
today and and take a look at okay
here's the content that i've posted just
look at your insights and figure out
what piece of content got you the most
new follows and i'm going to make a
prediction i'm going to lim here and say
uh for 98 of you it's going to be the
content that was
shared the most it's not saves it's not
likes
it's not comments it's the the content
that was shared the most is the content
that's getting you the most ideal
followers
and you know like i said the more you
post the more you grow so i want to give
you some tips because who doesn't need
some time saving tips right
okay so let me blow through these
because i know we're coming up on the
end the first thing is
post reposting proven viral content
that's in your niche
from the original creator but with their
permission
now there's some controversy around this
you know there's a lot of accounts that
share viral content and they don't tag
the original creator and they don't ask
for permission but for most people
myself included
if you want to share my content
you don't have to ask for my permission
please you want to promote me for free
to your followers go for it i mean
recently i had um someone point out to
me that there's there's somebody on uh
that started a podcast where they
they're sharing clips of other people's
podcasts and and mine's featured on a
whole bunch of them and they're like you
know my team said do you want to go
after them and you know tell them to
take it down for copyright infringement
i said hell no they're like it's like
they're running a commercial for me no
one's going to listen to that podcast
and say
wow i really like that chalene johnson i
want to do business with this guy
they're going to go i would really like
this chalene johnson i gotta figure out
how to find her podcast
so you know when we're sharing other
people's viral content provided you are
tagging them and providing you're asking
for permission
if it's within your niche then that's
one less piece of content you have to
create it's giving them exposure it's
reciprocity it's a an abundance mindset
there's enough to go around you don't
have to worry about like oh they're but
they're my competition i don't know i
don't think that way
um and i encourage you to do that these
are accounts i want to share with you
where we've followed this strategy okay
so take a look at this all right so look
at push me daily that's the first one
everything you see in green is all
content we've
shared with the permission
of other creators
look at home workouts for you
every single piece of content
is from another creator that we've
shared promoted them shouted out their
account
and you might think gosh i'm shouting
out someone else's account yes but look
at what it's done to our account it's
blown up because our account then
becomes a very valuable account if
you're looking for
really intense workouts at home with
very little
equipment same thing marketing impact
academy again green represents content
that we're posting where we're shouting
out somebody else but it's content that
falls within our niche
okay
and the reason why this works
even with your own content is because
less than six percent of your followers
are seeing your average feed post on
average
and they're people who are higher
congratulations but most of the time
people they a either forgotten about it
or they never saw it
so what you should be doing is instead
of like constantly reinventing the wheel
take your stuff that's already performed
really well and just either tweak it or
just completely repost it let me share
with you what we put this to the test
okay
and this is a case study we did this on
our accounts for 30 days this is a
30-day case study
now i have virtual assistants who help
us with all these accounts but check out
what happened so here are the accounts
that we tested it on
for 30 days what you're looking at all
the green
was was content that we had we had
posted before it was so old content we
repurposed we had posted it before
within the last six months
okay
all of that was old content would you
like to see what it did to our numbers
this is going to blow your freaking mind
these accounts 30 days
no new content and they had a 244
increase of new followers
i'm like why are we why do we try so
hard why do we keep thinking we have to
come up with new content let's just like
improve the stuff or tweak the stuff or
repost the stuff that we already know
worked
good
right strong
are we throwing up 189 engagement up 178
insane
so here's our quick little recap of the
five things you need to do moving
forward take a screenshot of that
and i'm here for your questions
chalene johnson uh that that last one
was powerful growth recap though uh you
gotta niche down what is your niche let
us know in the uh comments if you're
watching this on the replay are you
clear on your niche or are you a little
bit foggy are you multi-passionate
secondly how optimized is your bio do
you know your bio third post more reals
fourth share worthy content oh sorry do
you need that back up again i was
reading it but fifth is
a study that insights is uh really study
what works and if you want to learn more
uh of course uh chalene is the expert
and think businessweek.com is a place
where there's four different workshops
to choose from um they're all happening
this week and so definitely make sure to
register for all that free training
there should be a link in the
description or you can check a clickable
link in the comments you know if you're
new to chalene i know some people who
saw a kind comment of somebody that was
pumped for all your training and that
was pumped to meet you
i've known shalene now for five years
and she's changed my personal life and
business
her her team her family
and uh ultimately her content and
eventually her program called the
marketing impact academy uh but one of
the reasons why i love chalene is
because first of course you got to be
good at what you do why would you want
to learn from somebody who can't give
you real tips actionable tips um but
deeper than that um
here at think media especially we're so
purpose driven and values driven that
getting to know chalene and uh her
husband brett how long you guys been
married now
27 years 27 years married uh brock and
sierra her kids uh we had a profound
conversation a while back where she had
mentioned early in her career um
when you've got your peers you've got
people that are going everywhere
speaking at every event doing everything
to grow their brand and of course as
ambitious leaders if you're listening to
this and entrepreneurs you can kind of
full
you can feel pulled into that and shalin
shalina's had just
incredible success but one of the things
that i learned from that conversation is
there's a difference between ambition
and toxic ambition
and one of the things i respect the most
about chalene and her family is that
while building a world-class business
that she purposely reduced her travel so
she could be at every single one of
brock's football games and every single
one of sierra's track meets not only
that
not just seeing results on the external
but seeing and getting to travel to
southern california and work with her
team a couple different times or film
videos and film podcasts with her i got
to meet her team
i got to see that the people around her
were healthy and doing well and that
they have a culture and that she deeply
cares about people so i know this isn't
about instagram training here but i just
want you to know and acknowledge you
chalene for just man your influence in
my life over the years
and just
just those other things that i think
ultimately matter most because what good
does it is it to get to the top of the
mountain at the sacrifice of the things
that matter most and i know people go
through things and that sometimes there
can be
reasons for uh you know a marriage being
toxic or whatever but honestly there's
too many
divorces happening too many people that
are prioritizing business over family
there's just too much there's too many
fake people that they look at on the
outside for a while but then kind of you
know the house of cards comes tumbling
down so i'm just grateful
for your depth of character and your
world-class education and social media
and business and just want to say i
appreciate you and so saying all that
for those in our world too if you're
just meeting chalene um she's a lot of
fun i like the fact that she can crush
it on the slopes snowboarding she
she lipsticks and raps to a lot of
really hardcore rappers i mean not just
like surface level like crossover pop
rap but like really gangster rap like i
mean it's pretty crazy the level that
you take it um but just amidst all of
that social media stuff as well i'm just
so grateful for your family
um and values and character and
integrity and legacy in the industry um
i really appreciate you yeah it's it's
hard to stay focused these days i think
that's important to you know like at the
end of a training to say something like
that because
um we can get all caught up and like do
more do more do more do more i'm not
doing enough everybody's doing more than
me
and i i do think it is really important
for us to constantly be reminding each
other
to stay focused to stay the course to to
know and put in writing what's important
to you otherwise you will get caught up
in like okay well this is just a quick
opportunity or we're going to slow down
after this happens and it really is
important that you just do things
with thoughtful consideration and
thinking about like what is the next
right step for me
that is also in alignment with my
priorities my values and um you know
what what matters most to me
so i'm glad you said it beautiful and so
anyways wit for uh time and i hope
you'll be getting value hit like if you
haven't been to thinkbusinessweek.com
definitely head over there because uh
that's where if you want more chalene
johnson it's a business
growth week is happening and i'm excited
because um this has happened in april 21
through the 24th it's all free and uh
monetize your social media how to slay
sales without selling four secrets to
business success and the more money
master class i mean i i don't i'm not
even trying to gush but literally the
impact i was just telling our team this
morning uh you're in brett johnson's
just how you've helped me with money
management stewardship of finances
business operations
focus productivity um yeah we we take a
lot of notes directly inside of your
products and programs and this also uh
observing from from afar as well screen
shotting your stories screenshotting
brett's stories stock pics
uh and uh it's just y'all add so much
value and so uh anyways uh definitely
reserve your seat um for the uh free
workshops think businessweek.com
and um chilean johnson final word for
entrepreneurs um you know
you're you've you've done used car sales
earlier
yeah
people may not know that uh that they
could go to their local fitness club and
probably find piyo on the options of
classes to take yeah you're the inventor
of piyo and all kinds of fitness stuff
so you just you're you are a serial
entrepreneur yeah and those listening to
this i would argue kind of r as well
these days it's you know building up
instagram and then eventually maybe i
make a course or i want to write a book
you're a number one new york times
bestselling author my god you've done a
lot of different things can you speak to
us to just the seasons of
entrepreneurship and whether we feel
like we're on a mountaintop right now or
in a valley right now
just what you've learned through the
highs and lows of business you just
haven't just had success you've been
punched you know
metaphorically maybe physically but
you've been much
metaphorically you know by hard
financial months and setbacks and and
all entrepreneurs have can you just give
us some encouragement to keep going as
we're building our businesses um yeah
yeah so it's dangerous i think for
sometimes for people to hear
someone like myself like kind of a
resume or
a list of our successes because then it
makes you feel like you should be doing
all these things too but the reason why
we brett and i have been able to
successfully grow
seven different businesses
in
seven different industries
all you know million dollar businesses
is because we didn't do them at the same
time
um so i when we have stumbled when we
made really big
financial mistakes it's because
i started like i don't want to say
getting greedy but like oh i better do
that too
where my work wasn't done and my
attention wasn't finished on the project
that we were in so every one of those
accolades that you just shared thank you
so much but they i didn't do any of
those all at the same time like i just
focused for two years on growing my
email list so that when i did launch my
book it would you know would be on the
new york times bestseller list um when
we started uh when i i sold our fitness
business um then we stopped doing any
fitness related content and i just
focused exclusively on growing our
online marketing community you know and
then grew that so to a place where it
was you know thriving and we're talking
like four or five years before it really
i could almost set it and forget it and
then think about the next opportunity
but it's kind of like children
you know if you if you try to adopt five
at once you know like that's wonderful
but can you really give each one of them
adequate attention
and i i personally don't think you can i
think you you need to create that solid
foundation for each opportunity and the
way to do that is to remember that you
don't have to do this thing forever
but you should look at all the things
you're interested in and pick the one
where you're like
i number one i'm really interested in
this one but the opportunity the timing
of this particular one is now
you know so maybe you've got five things
that you're really interested in you're
like i i could i could um launch a
podcast and uh i i i'm focused on my
affiliate sales and i'm also trying to
build my chiropractic
practice
pick the one where and double down the
one we because you're interested in all
those so just pick the one where you're
like there's the best opportunity
for growth and scale
based on the season that i'm in
and what's happening in the world and
and go with that pick one and double
down
pick one and double down the power of
focus shaleen johnson thank you so much
hey can we show love to chalene in the
comments today hit the like button thank
you so much for being on the
uh growth video live show shilling
johnson is one of our speakers uh but
growth video live still a few weeks out
i think we're almost 40 days out and so
uh if you want to really get some
valuable content uh this week highly
recommend checking out think
businessweek.com where you can get four
more sessions from chalene also uh if
you haven't subscribed to our podcast
the think media podcast shalene's
episode is dropping on there we are
recently in san diego together at an
event called social media marketing
world um and she adds a lot more content
all about niche uh friends i am so
grateful for you thank you for being
here today smash the like button if you
got value out of the training if you
want to catch the replay it'll be up
here um as well if you joined late my
name is sean cannell rhymes with youtube
channel this has been the growth video
live show and i will see you in a future
episode peace